here's an interesting idea why do we die
at all why is natural selection never
given us an immortal species have you
even thought about that yeah yeah I have
never reached a conclusion but I was
figured you live long enough who will
especially up until recent history only
long enough to recognize it was all
crazy hustle it's a philosophical I
believe or a scientific answer here's
here's one answer for why we're not
immortal
okay so if you think about it why would
natural selection not have created a
creature that lived forever right not
why did why should we die yeah okay so
here's that one answers it's not known
for sure if this is the answer but this
is a good answer
imagine they're two different kinds of
things that can kill you intrinsic
causes and extrinsic causes so things
inside your body that result in you
dying defects diseases and so forth or
things outside your body like accidents
lightning strikes trees fall and you
just die and so forth because it's
impossible to eliminate all extrinsic
causes because some people are going to
die from accidents it would be if
inefficient from the point of view of
evolution to evolve to be immortal
because we would have all this capacity
to be immortal we would have these
bodies capable of immortality which
let's say would be evolutionarily
demanding like to evolve anything like
an eye or a brain or strong any any
quality lactase right we like we talked
about earlier you you don't have lactase
persistence into adulthood because it's
not needed so evolution doesn't waste
anything there'd be no reason for that
so there'd be no the there would there
there would be no reason the argument
goes to evolved immortality because
inevitably some people would be killed
eventually by accidents anyway so unless
you can create a world in which there
are no accidents there no extrinsic
causes of death it would be if
inefficient from an evolutionary point
of view to evolve immortality so death
the reason we die naturally some people
think is that the reason we die
naturally is that there are unnatural
causes of death in the world
like accidents if we could eliminate the
unnatural causes so that no where no no
time ever were we ever killed by trees
falling or lightening strikes or things
like that then actually over time we
would evolve to live indefinitely this
is the theory it's crazy idea
it is fascinating but do you think that
nature had that sort of foresight well
it's not a foresight but that's how
natural selection works mmm think about
like if I have suddenly magically
transformed your body at great expense
to make you capable of immortality and
then two days where now you're hit by a
bus I've wasted all that effort but if
you only done to one person you wasted
that effort if you did it to other
people you have the potential to create
an incredibly wise person with a
thousand years of life and experience
and education we died he also have died
so everyone eventually would die from
these extrinsic causes so personal ah
well no that's that's that's the
assumption in the model yeah if it's not
perhaps if in fact there are no external
in which you're never struck by
lightning never hit by a bus never a
tree branch right then then the theory
is that we would have evolved to be
immortal so that's almost like the lot
the life that you live you're inevitably
going to get killed by extrinsic causes
yes if you extend that life to a
thousand years then it's absolutely yes
yes therefore why bother
that's just living in a bubble just
terrified of the world the falling rocks
we can get yeah but you can't transport
you can't take this theory and this
model and apply to an individual in an
individual life it's about how our
species evolved it's not about how
usually live your life I mean right it's
also true I don't think you should live
your life afraid